favi jpg money meraviglio fa vj sei un
dj mi mancava ragazzi credete
minchia che drop
[Musica]
tutti ragazzi e benvenuti questo video
sono fa vj oggi domenica quindi siamo su
happy uil siamo grati a 80 episodi di
happy feet mica paura sentirselo dire
come solo come ho resistito
tanti episodi va bene cominciamo ragazzi
perché non ho idea di che cosa come
perché puoi scegliere corre del
background facciamo orange la mia vita è
completa devo scegliere l'arma call call
col mouse quindi spies ma perché provoca
lanciafiamme ragazzi non è così posso
fare alla madonna è di di gelo albè
super lancia mi è caduto in testa
davvero mi sono voluto su serie benelli
m4 questa è la m4 di benelli sticazzi
come salta bombing aa profeti lancio il
telecomando
ma la vacca bene questo è tutto legato
da uno dei migliori livelli che abbia
giocato fino alla pittura per
devo prendere il look l'ho preso cantal
io che dovrei stiracchiati ecco bravo
perfetto allunga la gamba senti il
tendine e una è 2 e cioè o cazzo quando
dico che devi fare stretching devi far
stretching perché sennò succede questo
devo vincere io quindi smettila di ci
sono degli arpioni bene la gamba senza
stretching alla fine ha vinto tar pur o
mi chiama porranno complimenti su questa
ok
come non detto ragazzi hanno fatto prima
è un genio ma cosa ha sì stronzo
però però liuc ha vinto l'importante è
che vinca luke poi fotte 6 fuck yeah al
punto o questo questo lo so fare perché
devo schivare è la madonna per come
faccio sì ma è imposto zio a cannes è
impossibile a meno che non mi infili
sembra che sia inglobando un arpione
niente niente niente niente ragazzi sono
vivo sono incastrato nell'angolo nessuno
nessuno può uccidermi
era questo che intendevo con stretching
maledizione parti senza lo stretching
sarei morto ragazzi fate stretching da
chi m'ammazza ma voglio ska morire prima
di cadere
invece no no no ascolta zio è questo lo
devo fare con eddy perché se non sono
capace frate solivo so io sono morto lo
facevo mi scarso per lo stile bravo zio
cosa fa ha capito tutto e non lo sapevo
che fosse così pro jolo ecco un chiesto
a casa ragazzi perché non salvano save
billy ma aveva anche la mamma
ti piace la serie alic parkour fermino a
clic su start che minchia che deficente
che sono sì sì oddio oddio guarda lo
guardano ma no non è possibile
mezz'ora fa sta cagate poi ho sbagliato
il canestro un genio ex versus zombie
cos'è allora perché cesta musica epica e
perché quel [ __ ] una band appello
del si sente il baseball
esatto è una roba che mi riesce molto io
so fare solo così col braccio se
inforcare le persone lo hai del
polpettone zio uomo questo è per lei
gliela regala no no no no no no non ne
usufruisca così tanto quella che arriva
con l'ananas cosa fa e per me posso
affettarla da quattro esatto anni scorsi
pensò fa suonare la scure lei con sono
riuscito ad uccidere l'ultima cosa fa
stupisce ogni volta che inizi mitsubishi
e la madonna sono già morte ho già perso
ti regalo delle caramelle se stai calmo
problemi ai colavita cosa ti ha fatto
tua madre quando sei nato non puoi cosa
vuoi da me sembrava la versione brutta
di pacman quest'uomo non sono sicuro che
sia un uomo però so darti io che da
mangiare come è possibile
hp sono ancora con gli occhi sono ancora
che gli ovetti so stronzo
sei la persona più inutile dell'universo
chiaramente eto'o nessuno che anche come
concime parti o rifaresti cagare anzi se
facessi cagare saresti buono anche come
concilia è un po alla madonna la figlia
non lo squartatore york tutto merito tuo
bravissimo di aid aids mica faccio
diving è la madonna
stavo per fare un tuffo incredibile il
problema che la piscina era dall'altra
parte come cazzo ci arrivo si ok la vita
sotto è stato la vita nove punti c
adventure cosa vuol dire quanto fa 9 più
10 ovviamente fa 21 appena e divertiti a
scuola mi mandano a scuola perché non so
fare 9 più di 10
questa è bella scuola realtà merda
sappia addio quanto fa 9 più 10 tuffo
tutto ragazzo ma color cosa vuol dire
vabbè è la barca la barca la banca
grazie va a fan culo sapere non voglio
sapere 9 più 10 deve far 21 torte gratis
la torta è una menzogna tutto quello che
devi sapere che ti sto portando a scuola
maledetti basta
chicca strada posso salvarmi no uno
contro uno stato schiacciato dalla
sapienza cosa che mi è successa più
volte solo un semplice livello creato da
sua best 360 nascono complimenti zio ma
che è ma cos'è lo arriva dall'altra
parte senza cadere
ok cracovia bagno deve vincere perfetto
amore che ultimamente io che stiamo
stiamo staccando i culi staten secco
devo resistere 10 secondi ce la posso
fare determinati ma spiegami massei
contare fino a non erano dieci secondi
questo è scritto 667 comfort da mad max
ear to start vai sul carico cv chi è
questo non va bene non voglio sapere
bravo problema è uno solo ragazzi gli
manca la bocca facciamo di cambiare le
scarpe che queste non si possono
guardare e siamo a posto ma domina di
cazzo sei mi sono scordato il pube la
ragazza ci facciamo un paio di livelli
miei perché sennò finiamo più
favi jpg money meraviglio fa vj sei un
dj mi mangia ragazzi credetemi minchia
che troppi
[Musica]
chi è lorenzo studi superiori brosso
parigi su per loro i prossimi
meraviglioso grazie grazie mi ha
ricordato che in realtà dovevo chiamarmi
super loro i prof
cosa molto per ha fatto da filippo la
vanga e andrea urso filippo lavanga nel
senso che se il livello è brutto tep io
e te picchio charanga sade fa vj tv mi
chiamo michele pio bongiorno buongiorno
anche a te quando facciamo i livelli gru
hd non è vero ti chiami gru officia fai
questo livello come un fa vj ok arrivo
facile share user fatemi capire il senso
famigie tv the kids are to win
livelli riempiono la mia vita vuota e
miserabilmente priva di emozioni grazie
anche ragazzi concluso che l'episodio
non fate domande perché ogni volta che
faccio i vostri veli ogni [ __ ]
episodio sempre faccio con i ragazzi se
vi dove piaciuto l'assenza sul documento
è un mi piace ai capace di facebook e
come di adottata nella sezione
[ __ ] [ __ ] se ne saresti
discreti e spin minchiate tutto va bene
ci vediamo al prossimo vinto nell aria